you might be able to get access to
modern warfare 2 sooner rather than
later thanks to the call of duty league
plus get an xbox with no money down via
verizon and more psvr 2 details on
today's game spot news
on sunday august 7th the call of duty
league will be giving away beta codes
for modern warfare 2 to lucky attendees
of that day's championship matches
either in person at the galen center in
los angeles or viewing online via live
stream if you're watching online you'll
need to stream at least 60 minutes of
the broadcast at which point you'll be
entered into a random price draw for one
of the early beta access codes other
methods for gaining early access to the
beta includes the usual pre-order model
with activision confirming that
playstation owners will be able to play
the beta five days earlier than any
other platform no official details on
when the beta begins but insiders have
unofficially stated that mid-september
is the targeted date with the full game
dropping on october 28th until then you
can check out the mercenaries of fortune
update for war zones starting tomorrow
july 27th the model t800 and t1000
terminators will be available via
operator bundles zombies are coming to
rebuff island and more on the mobile
side of call of duty a ghost in the
shell crossover will be coming to the
phone and tablet based shooter on august
3rd the anime collab will feature
operator skins a themed event and a new
battle royale location inspired by the
show no word on if you'll be able to
play as scarlett johansson need a
console to play call of duty on verizon
the phone and internet giant will soon
begin offering xbox all access a
subscription plan that bundles the
series s or x console and xbox game pass
ultimate beginning thursday july 28th
anyone can get via verizon an xbox
series s with a two-year membership to
game pass ultimate for 25 dollars a
month or an xbox series x with two years
of game pass ultimate for 35 dollars a
month while two years is quite the
commitment both plans end up being
cheaper than buying a console outright
and paying for game pass separately
month to month if your console of choice
is playstation and you've been eyeing
the upcoming psvr ii sony just announced
a bunch of new details you can expect
when you get your hands on the hardware
like the metaquest 2 which was just
announced to be getting a 100 price
increase in august users will be able to
create a vr operation boundary in their
space if they leave the confines of it
the headset will switch to a view of the
real world thanks to its built-in
cameras psvr2 will also offer users the
ability to switch to that view at any
time with the press of a function button
on the headset all this is taken one
step further with users able to scan
their environment and the device
seemingly able to auto detect what is a
flat accessible surface and what is an
obstacle so players won't solely have to
rely on manually creating their
boundaries psvr 2 will offer broadcast
functionality not only of the game being
played but with a connected ps5 hd
camera capturing the user themselves and
overlaying them on top of the gameplay
like the original psvr psvr2 users will
not only be able to play vr titles but
interact with their ps5 via a virtual
screen sony is dubbing cinematic mode
while vr content will be displayed in
4000 by 2040 high dynamic range with a
90 hertz or 120 hertz refresh rate
cinematic mode will display non-vr
content in 1920x1080 hdr with a 2460 or
120hz refresh rate so if you plan to use
the psvr2 to play non-vr games just know
that they will not be displayed in 4k
and that is it for today's gamespot news
if you are one of the ones looking to
win one of those modern warfare 2 beta
codes we wish you the best of luck and
we'll see you tomorrow right here on
gamespot